[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous à l'occasion
des élections municipales ça aux cadis
change de formule
bertrand caruge et moi nous recevrons en
alternance deux candidats par jour à
raison de cinq minutes par personne
notre invité ce matin max pied bonjour
bonjour vous êtes candidat à saint
joseph vous allez conduire la liste
ambitions joséphine qu'est ce qui vous
pousse à vous présenter monsieur pied
mais tout simplement parce que je suis
un enfant de la commune et que j'ai
décidé de ne pas rester l'armé au pied
spectateurs peut-être désolé est proposé
à ma commune une alternative quelque
chose de nouveau pour son avenir
vous êtes vous étiez vous avez été
adjoint au maire de saint joseph
raymond ça fâche le peintre 20-15 à à
2001 c'est cela c'est bien et vous étiez
mais un peu en retrait qu'est-ce qui
vous pourquoi vous revenez qu'est-ce qui
nous il ya des choses qui vous dérange
dans votre commune qui ne vont pas bien
absolument pas mais moi je crois que la
démocratie impose un certain nombre de
règles
nous étions aux affaires à l'époque la
population avait estimé que moi je pense
que il y avait une certaine lassitude
peut être une du pouvoir en place et
donc avaient fait un autre choix
donc moi je respecte ce choix je me suis
un petit peu retiré tout en en regardant
ce qui se passait je n'ai pas voulu
interférer interférer dans le débat
politique
et puis maintenant bon moi je pense que
après 18 années
ben je pense que c'est le moment on ne
peut pas indéfiniment soit porter la
critique ou faire des remarques et je
n'ai jamais rien proposé alors là j'ai
décidé de devenir et de proposer quelque
chose
alors justement qu'est ce que vous
proposez quels sont les grands axes de
vos programmes de votre programme pardon
alors effectivement ce ne sera pas un
programme mirobolant avec un catalogue
d'actions
je propose tout simplement à la
population que la municipalité et
reviennent aux fondamentaux c'est à dire
les fondamentaux c'est tout ce qui
touche au cadre de vie et le bien vivre
le bon vivre à saint joseph
il ne fait plus bon vivre à saint joseph
là je ne peux pas dire cela mais
simplement il faut que nous ayons la
garantie que ce que par exemple je vais
trouver ben je puisse me faire prospérer
pour les générations à venir
je veux parler par exemple de
l'électrification rurale qui est
quasiment fait à 100% les voiries les
équipements publics
les équipements sportifs enfin tout ce
qui fait qu'une municipalité doit amener
du confort mais ça existe déjà alors
tout cela existe et c'est pour ça que je
dis qu'on ne part pas de rien on ne part
pas de rien et par conséquent il faut
tout faire pour inscrire et saint joseph
dans les cinémas et des dix quinze
années à venir
c'est à dire alors parce que pense
qu'ils ont moins de succès que j'ai
envie de vous poser comme question si
tout ça est déjà fait pourquoi vous
présentez parce que non seulement il
faut continuer mais il faut l'entretenir
il faut faire en sorte que ce patrimoine
là soient productifs il faut faire en
sorte que les générations à venir
puisque de trouver dans l'état où on
nous le donne donc il s'agit pas de
c'est à dire bon c'est déjà fait puis on
se croise les bois ya plus rien à faire
non il faut maintenir notre patrimoine
les atouts sont des atouts très
importants la commune de ses effets très
bien équipée et il faut surtout lui
donner une orientation je dis bien notre
vie c'est pas un programme c'est pas un
catalogue
c'est une politique qu'il faut mettre en
place pour les 15 à 20 prochaines années
une politique qui dirait quoique rendre
attractif là encore une fois le
territoire si ça il faut rendre
attractif le team temps ce qu'est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on dit ça quand on dit
ça il faut faire en sorte que des
personnes soient intéressés par notre
commune soit pour venir y habiter soit
pour venir investir au faire des
affaires et développé un petit peu son
économie donc il faut qu'elle soit
attractive
parce que on est sur la difficulté pour
nous c'est que nous sommes en périphérie
de grands centres mais nous sommes dans
une communauté d'agglomération et nous
devons faire valoir nos atouts donc
saint joseph ne peut pas rester que la
ville de droit nous assumons le relevé
notant mais nous voulons être attractif
pour ceux qui y sont qu'ils puissent
trouver tous les équipements et le
confort qu'il faut et ceux qui veulent
venir puissent trouver aussi des
des emplacements fin des endroits pour
pouvoir prospérer
donc vous re dynamiser le bourg aussi
par exemple par exemple cela fait partie
d'une priorité parce que ce beau a
besoin d'être un petit peu
dépoussiérez vos amis au goût du jour il
ne reste pas beaucoup de temps entre les
candidats déjà déclarés et ceux qui sont
en voie de l'être
on compte à peu près huit personnes ça
fait un peu beaucoup non c'est le jeu
démocratique
il faut s'en féliciter qu'un saint
joseph et une vitalité de jeunes fin de
personnes d'hommes et de femmes capables
de pouvoir faire des propositions de la
population donc saint joseph est une
ville qui attire voix semblablement mais
encore il faut il faut que nous fassions
encore mieux monsieur pied je vous
remercie son caddie est terminé merci de
nous avoir suivis merci
[Musique]